- There's something quite
primal about being in a tree,
something that just feels really safe.
It's just great.
Go climb a tree.
(acoustic guitar)
An arborist is somebody who
takes care of the trees.
We prune, maintain, and
remove if dangerous.
Really the whole healthcare of a tree.
In Melbourne, we're quite
lucky in the ranges.
There's trees up there
that are 85, 90 meters.
Really, really big trees.
At the moment, I'm about 24,
22, 24 meters up a tree,
in a beautiful old red gum.
This old tree we're in today
is maybe 250 years old,
and it would be such a
shame to the landscape
to lose something like this.
Is it dangerous?
It probably, yeah, it
must be really dangerous.
I mean it's one of the most
dangerous jobs in the world,
apparently.
Every single tree has something different
that you have to put into it.
That hole is just big enough
to take one of the syringes
and actually prevent all these leaf-miners
from attacking those leaves.
Working with trees and understanding trees
and having a respect for trees
is the only way I think you
can really then cut the trees.
The thing is, sometimes a
tree needs to come down.
If there's an obvious failure,
or disease or something,
then we're the best ones to
come out, remove it safely,
and advise about how we can replant.
We're here actually trying to preserve
and look after the trees,
because we very much have
an affection for them.
(acoustic guitar)